ELIAS PINTO: Whoa,
it's dark in here.
JASON BISSON: I'm glad we
have these cave lights.
Did you charge yours?
ELIAS PINTO: Oh, of course not.
Geez, I guess we're going
to be partially in the dark
here today.
JASON BISSON: You know who's
personally in the dark?
Some of our cloud
customers out there,
with multiple logging platforms.
And they're busy searching for
who did what, where, and when.
The great news is,
at Google Cloud,
we have a solution that will
help our customers get out
of the dark by
exporting those audit
events into a popular logging
platform called Splunk.
You want to check it out?
ELIAS PINTO: Let's do it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
JASON BISSON: So the first
thing we're going to need to do
is create a topic.
In this case, we're just
going to name it gcp2splunk.
We're going to click
on the Create button.
And the topic is going to
be created quite quickly.
The next step is to
create the export sync.
To do this, we're going
to open up a Cloud Shell.
And then we're going to download
a script from a Google Cloud
Storage bucket that has
the G Cloud commands
from our solution guide.
Now that the script
is downloaded,
we're going to pass
it the argument
of the organizational name.
And that's important
to note because when
we run that command
with the filter,
it will include the
children records.
And that will include the
folders and projects--
any events underneath the org.
Now you'll notice that from
those G Cloud commands,
there's a couple
of messages there.
And one is indicating
a new service
account has been created.
And it's asking for
that service account
to have the Pub/Sub
publisher role.
The reason that it needs
a Pub/Sub publisher
role is because those
exported events from the sync
are going to go to the topic.
So now we'll go back
to the Pub/Sub topic.
We'll click on Permissions, and
we'll paste in the new service
account.
We're going to need to give it
that Pub/Sub publisher role,
and we'll click on Add.
So now we have a topic.
We have an export sync.
The next step that we'll need
to do is create a subscription.
And this is a
subscription that Splunk
will have to pull those
messages from the topic.
So we'll click on
New Subscription.
We're going to
name it splunk2gcp.
The delivery type
is going to be Pull.
And then we'll click on Create.
And just like the topic,
that happens pretty quickly.
So now we have a
subscription for Splunk
to pull the messages.
The next thing we're
going to need to do
is we're going to have
to give Splunk permission
to come into the GCP platform
and pull the messages.
We'll go up to the IAM roles.
We'll click on Service Accounts.
Then we'll click on
Create Service Account.
And here, we're going
to name it splunk2gcp.
And we're going to give it
a couple of different roles
that are required.
One is going to be the
project viewer role.
The second role will be, of
course, the Pub/Sub subscriber
role.
So now we have two roles, a
viewer, and Pub/Sub subscriber.
We're going to click on
Furnish a New Private
Key, with a key type of
JSON, and click Create.
You'll notice on
the left-hand side
that that JSON key
has been downloaded.
And we have a couple
of warnings there
about protecting that key.
And it's very important
that you consider
integrating this process
into your secrets management
platform, because this will
give access to the GCP platform.
And also shred any local
copies that you have there.
So now that we understand that
we have to secure this key,
we'll click Close.
And we'll head back to the topic
and try to publish a message.
We'll click on Topics, and we'll
click on Publish a Message.
And we'll type in, "Help,
I'm in a cave with clowns,"
because that's not scary.
And we'll click on Publish.
The next thing we could
do is we can leverage
the metrics to explore in
Stackdriver to check out
that messages are being
published successfully
and can be used for
troubleshooting in the future.
So that's it.
We now have audit events from
the Google Cloud Platform
ready to be pulled into
your Splunk instance,
making it easier to answer
the question of who did what,
where, and when.
ELIAS PINTO: So this does make
it easy for security ops teams
to have one place to
look for audit events.
JASON BISSON: You got it.
ELIAS PINTO: Don't forget to
like, comment, and subscribe.
And if you're working
on any cool projects
and would like to get
in contact with us,
click on the link
in the description.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]